um pouquinho ler eu sou kylie legado que
aquele caso do the voice king chong
falar a verdade o homem muito bom nunca
mulher todos nós sabem passar brincando
a mulher sou muito bom já que é porque
essa guerrinha cid homem mulher
ela tem já é muito tendo em vista a
humanidade que homem e mulher não vive
sem o outro porém é só assim com o
paraná eu sou melhor essa média não e
everton certeza que é vencer tantos a
cada 11 né
eu sou melhor que você quer dizer se me
por favor devolva minha costela volta a
volta
vou fazer um vídeo aqui de cinco dias
para os homens e cinco dicas às mulheres
a aires mas eu estou indeciso não sei se
sou homem ou mulher
aí não tem disco vamos começar com as
dicas que os homens seus amigos homem o
- vocês que me seguem no youtube vocês
que me segue no twitter que me segue
nesta quarta no site do facebook você
tem que entender uma coisa cólica é um
dom do demônio concentração do beleza
samba de sábado 25 dessa maneira ninguém
nem pra ser feliz é feliz vai doer nessa
corre caro quanto mulheres e namoradas
amigos tivessem concordado em ficar a
repassá pensei também não se acostumou
essa frescura não faz se sabe chin
absinto não volto quando cadu no bairro
lami diego pode ser benéfica conversando
e fazendo esquecer da dor fazer uma sala
sem apontar lá e faço meu de luz
o ju no nosso filho chutou o que
acontece é que você fala merda pra você
ficar com raiva você vai falar bem é
você vai ajudar só na maior você vai se
ajudar que ninguém mexer só que vai
ficar com muito feliz da sua vida e
beleza e segunda dica tem gente ppm ela
for muito diferente do que todo mundo
pensa que tem pena não tenho que a
mulher animal comum é o tempo que ela tá
de boa o mundo e odiando vou seguir a
dica que eu dou é o seguinte não
pergunta se ela está com o tpi porque
não sei o que a mulher tempo que ela
sabe que ela está na tpm mas se você
perguntar aí é que ela está na pm de com
força
o técnico toninho pmdb
estão falando que eu tô com tpm é isso
padilha ontem no topo tpi não exceda de
campo 16 é o sintoma cuidado com o que
você vai falar para sua namorada porque
o homem de fé se falam merda por você
pede desculpa fica de boca é um jogar o
game o jogador não deixou fazer qualquer
coisa agora quando você fala pra uma
mulher ela nunca nunca nunca vai
esquecer a moça era muito bonita nessa
roupa eu gostei dessa rocha só acha que
deixa um pouco gorda
dois anos depois amor que você acha de
hoje a gente fazer uma coisinha você na
não adiantou a fim de fazer nada não
quero não vai aguentar sabor daqui em
cima de tudo vai muito de samba balé
pinto disse não só a baleia orca ligando
pra você tempo e espaço gente eu desde
pequeno sempre tive mais amigos mulher
que o então acho que eu aprendi a
conviver com é só pedir a a entender
entendê las entender os mais entendê-las
que ciência é seu bolso e entender o
tempo eo espaço e quando a minha taxa
tiago não fica o que foi porque é alguém
que está vai pilha pilha cabeça da
criançada minha cria um hora de você
acha que atacou rádio t shirt lá deixei
que engloba o apoio falou não foi feito
para o deixou na quinta e última dica
homens homens prestem atenção nos
detalhes
quando você está namorando você vai sair
com a menina se ela sai bem bonita e
cheirosa ela é bonita e cheirosa pra
você aquela unha pintada bem clarinho
sozinho no cantão todo esse trabalho que
ela passou fazendo isso foi pra você
nossa partilha linha bonita nova ela
comprou pra você reparar essa bonita ela
se produzir para você então preste
atenção nos detalhes que ela fez isso
pra você não fazer sim servir esse vídeo
acabou de ver esse vídeo beleza não será
a sua namorada se passar no cabelo dela
tallinna e passa mais se vai passar no
até o finalzinho cabeça pela tela mesh
andré de cabeça e passa a ser sentir se
um pouco em celular na ponta alegre
aponta adulto mulher odeia conta do bom
no meio uma mulher o deputador porque
uma coisa que o sol não sabe que a
mulher se arruma muito pra outra mulher
o que é lésbica não ela quer sair bonita
mas ela quer que a amiga ou inimiga dela
é pai de família e teus hoje era talhado
então mulher bem aponta dupla observa
computador do cabelo dos outros também
então você vai observar a ponta do
cabelo da sua namorada você passa até o
final sentindo na ponta do pé ele passa
seus dias continue passando a mão no
cabelo dela passou a mão na cabeça até o
final não sentiu a conta dupla cortou o
cabelo você vai chegar para mais e assim
como o cabelo amor
nota 10 só não sei se ganha 500 pontos e
leva tomara que ela tenha cortado o
cabelo ela pode ter candidato a sair
futebol é assim mesmo ainda não têm
solução para tudo agora vamos às dicas
para as mulheres primeira dica as
mulheres que sofremos a resistência e
cólica a gente tem uma situação tudo bem
a gente tem que usar um tapete de
preguiça pra poder sair sangue os amigos
estão fazendo esquecer nunca me gera um
negócio duro na vida a gente acordou
mais triste do mundo você pensa que você
está mirando séculos e mira como função
a portaria dolly pedro duarte flash você
acertar onde no ralo do banheiro e nunca
me jogo você quer aí o infante o que
você estava de serviço não é informação
necessária é sentar pra você ver a bola
do vaso toda mijada é porque a gente é
por você chama de pouco nojento é porque
a gente é pouco é gente é porque admira
direito mas não tem controle do negócio
tanto mulher requer muita atenção mulher
adora atenção e isso é bom que o bota
tem sua moeda só mulher de futebol ea
maioria é que todos nós maioria ama o
futebol e futebol é uma coisa que é uma
das únicas porque desvia o olhar do
homem da mulher
a outra coisa é o futebol onde que dá
pra você termina que a mulher tá
namorando e chuva para assistir futebol
dele teve um bichinho só o amor de homem
o comando bola uma guia ocorre um carro
na bola porque se uma bancada da bola
não assiste novela é um monte de gente
fingindo que é uma pessoa não é torná se
especulou não pode colocar que eu vou me
colocar na boca no bosque de número 3 a
gente gosta o saco porque costa é que
lançar este ano só porque é isso aí pra
cima no sol porque costa é doença
conselho não é porque corre porque se
incomoda que tá costas a quem também
está acostumado
o site antecipou na sequer se coçando o
saco do micuim opa tudo bem está como
está agora à espera dele pode ser
constatado a itens como adaptação no
meio eu tô passando meu deixa de número
4 um homem e deixou orgulhoso pra carai
de veda a gente sempre vai querer que
gostaria que o nosso melhor nosso beijo
foi o melhor já provou na hora porque a
gente é o melhor também não importa o
jeito para eu cara é um curioso ele quer
sempre ter sido melhor pra você que está
em último e primordial dica para a
mulher qualquer movimento muito brusco
contra o saco do ing e mais leve que eu
falei da cólica no começo que mandou
beleza banda da pessoa portadora de um
chute no saco s globeleza sambando com a
escola a mangueira e beija-flor sambando
tudo bem porque na barriga no carro
abandonou o ovo não pode se levantar no
saco parece que dói assim é parece que a
alma quer sair do povo dizendo jesus me
leva pelo amor de deus você dá um show
no sábado a pessoa cair no chão e
começar a rir não é porque não tá doida
porque não quero chorar na sua frente
obrigados a assistir vídeos é aqui eu
queria que você comentasse aqui embaixo
que você acha mais curioso nos homens o
que você acha mais curioso nas mulheres
se você viu esse vídeo no facebook eu
peço que você volte lá e clique em
curtir pra me ajudar e clique em gostei
aqui no youtube se você vai gostar
também quem escrevesse aqui em baixo pra
você nunca mais perdeu o fio do canal tá
tudo bem você vai ser a avisar e muito
obrigado é não é